[Applaudissements]
wang
les tortues ninja
c'est toute mon enfance je ne peux pas
compter le nombre d'heures que j'ai
passés devant ce dessin animé une
cuillère de choco pops dans la bouche
votre et en pyjama devant la télé avec
mes copains ont rejoué les épisodes dans
la cour ça commençait souvent comme ça
j'aurai des rats kidnappé nos amoureuse
alors il n'y eut ni deux je sentais
l'appel du justicier monter en moi je
filais dans mon cartable fouillé dans
mon cartable récupérer mon katana en
plastique et mon bandeau bleu pour
devenir leonardo libéré mais super
pouvoirs pour libérer ma fiancée je
retournais sous le préau pour y trouver
mes partenaires
zadig le bagarreur était devenu raphaël
la tortue rouge avec csii piquant mehdi
le rigolo de la bande était michelangelo
bandeau orange et nous traquons quant à
dimitri il était devenu donatello le
plus posé avec le bo c'est à dire le
grand bâton de combat des ninjas nos
aventures pouvait durer des heures
plusieurs récré même simplement
entrecoupé de quelques pauses technique
de temps en temps du genre un tour à
l'infirmerie pour un saut ninja d'un peu
trop haut ou c'était mieux une pause à
la cantine bien mérité avec tes grande
grande grande pizza
voilà en substance
nos jeux d'enfants c'était ça une cause
juste des super-pouvoirs du matériel un
petit peu et puis des partenaires et ce
qui est drôle quand je regarde ces mots
c'est que j'ai l'impression que beaucoup
d'années après ma vie n'a pas beaucoup
changé
aujourd'hui je travaille à la corde et
sommes une équipe de 20 personnes et on
s'organise à peu près comme ça notre
cause on l'appelle notre raison d'être
évolutive alors ce mot on n'a pas
inventé il nous vient d'un livre qui
s'appelle reinventing organization écrit
par frédéric laloux je vais tenter de
détailler chaque terme pour vous pour
que vous compreniez raison d'être
ça veut simplement dire notre raison à
tous en tant que groupe d'exister c'est
à dire pour nous les clients les
fournisseurs l'équipe
notre raison d'être en tant
qu'entreprise nôtre parce que c'est tous
ensemble qu'on a défini cette raison
d'être
lors de journées d'equipe entre de
travail en équipe complète et évolutive
parce que justement en fonction des
conclusions de ces journées de travail
elle évolue aujourd'hui si je devais en
donner un aperçu vraiment très succinct
et très résumé ce serait aidé chaque
personne à s'accomplir pleinement
on a dans toutes nos actions à chaque
fois qu'on en comprend entreprend un
projet en équipe
cette raison d'être évolutive en tête
c'est elle qui guide tous nos choix
ensuite on encourage chacun dans
l'équipe a libéré son super pouvoir
son super pouvoir c'est-à-dire sa raison
d'être personnel pourquoi un jour il est
arrivé sur terre ce sont ses passions
ses intérêts profonds dans la vie je ne
parle pas de diplôme là je ne parle pas
de chose qui ont été apprises à l'école
je parle d' intérêt profond qui fait qu
on les ferait même sans être payé c'est
pas si évident pour tout le monde
d'aller trouver son super pouvoir
parce qu'en fonction de notre parcours
scolaire ou professionnelle notre
éducation
on a parfois mis autour de ce super
pouvoirs une grande carapace de tortue
alors pour aider chacun à explorer son
coeur on utilise plusieurs techniques du
type coaching personnel du type
méditation dutil tenue de journaux
intimes
ce travail qui est très très personnelle
ne peut fonctionner que si nous avons le
soutien absolu des partenaires de
l'équipe
là c'est très important il n'y a qu'un
seul mot pour y arriver c'est la
confiance la confiance la confiance
absolue pour travailler la confiance il
faut simplement communiquer beaucoup on
communique en toute transparence
on a des outils de gestion de projets
qui sont vraiment très transparent le
but du jeu étant d'enlever les non dits
qui peuvent enlever la confiance
toute transparence ça veut dire par
exemple on attaque des sujets
extrêmement tabou je connais le montant
des salaires de tous mes partenaires
ensuite on communique en physique
puisque c'est très bien les outils web
c'est très bien aussi de téléphone mais
rien ne remplace vous le savez le fait
d'être tous réunis dans une même pièce
on va se voir régulièrement pour des
journées de travail en physique et enfin
on communique sur quelque chose qui est
parfois très oublié dans les équipes où
même dans les interactions humaines sur
nos faiblesses
j'ai parlé de super pouvoirs mais
paradoxalement c'est en communiquant
beaucoup beaucoup sur nos super
faiblesse d'un super faille que l'on
libère le super pouvoirs de nos
collègues pour le matériel
c'est assez simple chez nous on va
appeler ça l'argent
nous sommes une entreprise donc le
matériel le besoin physique de vivre
pour une entreprise va se trouver dans
l'argent et l'argent va souvent se
trouvait chez les clients donc même si
nous sommes des grands idéaliste nous
avons vite compris qu'il fallait qu'on
garde en tête toujours le besoin marché
sinon les grands projets qu'on imagine
malheureusement s'écroule et le stress
revient vite dans l'équipe des super
héros
ça ne sert à rien d'avoir des grands
rêves si à la fin de la fin du mois on
ne peut pas élever converse
convenablement nos familles ou financer
nos projets une autre façon d'illustrer
ces mots derrière moi le sembler
peut-être te raconter ma venue
aujourd'hui à tedx et là je vais devoir
vous faire une confidence
je ne suis pas venu donner une
conférence
non je suis un super héros en mission
être sur une scène et raconter des trucs
que j'ai écrit en fait c'est simplement
super pouvoirs c'est ce que j'ai
toujours fait dans ma vie depuis que je
suis petit j'ai écrit des fables des
poésies j'ai écrit des chansons et je
suis venu les raconter et récités en
public un super pouvoir
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
ça s'accompagne souvent malheureusement
ou heureusement de super faille chez une
personne qui monte sur la scène et je
pense que les onze intervenant avant moi
pourrait vous le dire la super faille
c'est la super trouille du super trou
c'est le super traque
alors pour gérer mon super traque cette
semaine comme le mois qui a précédé
j'ai pu compter sur le soutien
infaillible de nombreux partenaires que
je voulais remercier aujourd'hui en tout
premier lieu je voulais remercier toute
l'équipe tedx pour ce travail formidable
et particulièrement mes deux coaches
anne laure et charlotte qui m'ont
soutenu et vraiment soutenu je voulais
remercier mon équipe cordée qui m'a
envoyé au front pour être là devant vous
et nous représenter je voulais remercier
ma chérie qui est dans la salle et qui a
pris sur elle pour gérer mon trac est
mon meilleur ami qui est là aussi
il me reste à parler de la cause du coup
je suis pas venu ici juste pour vous
parler de tortues ninja alors si je
devais résumer en une phrase
ma raison la raison de ma présence ici
je dirais peut-être de vous avoir
encouragé en tout cas je l'espère à
libérer le super héros qui sommeille en
vous parce que c'est pas qu'une histoire
de tortues ninja ce qui se joue ici
ces mots derrière moi sont simplement
les quatre besoins humains fondamentaux
ce que les sages des anciens toute
civilisation toutes cultures confondues
nous ont toujours encouragé à combler
pour trouver si ce n'est le bonheur
éternel au moins le sens de la vie
l'auteur américain stephen kovy les a
résumé en ces termes
alors en rentrant chez vous cette nuit
dans votre petit lit de personnes
apparemment normal
réfléchissez quelques instants à ces
mots parce que le temps presse est ce
que vous entendez
c'est le monde qui appelle à l'aide et
qui a besoin de chacun de vous pour le
sauver
[Applaudissements]